sur ces images fournies par les
autorités ukrainiennes une attaque de
drone sur ceux qui semblent être une
grande base navale russe en Crimée il
s'agirait de la première attaque de ce
genre contre ce grand port pétrolier
côté russe on affirme qu'aucun dégâts
est assigné les attaques de drones se
multiplient ces dernières semaines
contre la flotte russe en mer Noire
alors que l'Ukraine poursuit sa
contre-offensive lancé début juin même
si Kiev ne cache pas que la reprise des
territoires conquis par la Russie et
plus compliqué que prévu
les combats sont durs les
occupants tentent de toutes leurs forces
d'arrêter nos gars les combats sont très
violents les secteurs de coupianz Liman
darkmouth marylinka Hafdi IFCA les
secteurs Sud c'est dur partout mais
quoique fasse l'ennemi c'est la force
ukrainienne qui domine
je dis la Russie a bombardé la ville de
Kerson blessant au moins 8 personnes et
causant des dégâts notamment sur la
cathédrale Sainte-Catherine et sur
plusieurs immeubles
ont été dans la salle de bain j'étais
allongé sur le canapé
au début je n'ai pas compris ce qu'il se
passait puis j'ai été en état de choc et
je me suis mise à hurler les autorités
russes sont de leur côté publiés ces
images de Sergei
le ministre heureuse de la Défense s'est
rendu dans la région de Liman dans l'est
de l'Ukraine sans que l'on connaisse la
date exacte de se déplacement faire
gaesso en a profité pour évoquer des
actions réussie autour de la ville de
l'imam